first let's show you this Russian army
video
[Music]
allow me to show you what the U.S army
put out last week middle girl raised by
two moms
I also marched for equality
I like to think I've been defending
freedom from an early age
standing at the altar to marry my other
mom
with such powerful role models I
finished high school at the top of my
class
I found it a way to prove my inner
strength and maybe shatter some
stereotypes along the way we're screwed
people can you imagine that Russian guy
coming up against that girl no offense
to that girl but if you give me a you
know East Village lesbian versus
Vladimir Putin who's gonna win